now one of his goals is to reopen
schools within the first
100 days now that's something that's
been on the minds of parents and
teachers now for what about
10 months now some say while ccsd has
made
a little progress much more needs to be
done orco mana explains
i'm dying to get back in front of these
kids kindergarten teacher kristen nigro
is hoping that day comes soon the clark
county school district board of trustees
recently voted
to allow in-person instruction for small
groups nigro says
her school doesn't have a concrete plan
yet but they are discussing who should
return
it helps me feel very good about
you know moving forward and to
potentially getting kids back into the
classroom president joe biden has
pledged to reopen
most k-12 schools within 100 days a new
executive action directs the departments
of education
and health and human services to give
guidance on how to safely do that amid
coven 19.
that's the direction we have to go in we
support that the local teachers union
says while small group instruction is a
good first step it wants ccsd to create
a proposal that follows the president's
lead
the timeline to do that is fast
approaching at some point
there's diminishing returns you can't
make those kind of decisions too late
parents say virtual learning is tough on
their kids but staying healthy
is also a priority i do have one of my
children that is
very worried about getting sick
it's all about creating a balance to
ensure students and staff are protected
i want to be able to see ccsd open up
schools
in a safe manner orco mana 8 news now
now the teachers union acknowledges that
the president's
100-day time frame is ambitious but
they do believe with proper support from
federal and local leaders
it could be possible